今ざっ肇社長で様損で本当に不思議なものがたくさん売ってるんですよ amazon
て本当にいろんな商品に溢れてる
いいものなのでしょ悪いものもあり今回はその謎を一つといてあげようと思いますはい
今回方のこちらです
ああああああん
商品はどこにいったはい骨やネス特恵三ツ矢サイダー見たかった完全三ツ矢サイダー
ですねはまってこれ超ルール改定案 sauer
ってなんかアマゾンで見たときに何も書いてなかったんですよドッキリ見えて野菜だし
て帰ってなくて説明欄とか全然なくて何か全然分からなかったんですけど見たらもう
めっちゃ書いてあるんですよ運が悪いと感がブルブル暴れだしてはっきり書いてあり
ます
そういう奴かえもーとなればキャッツするのかと思ったら全然爆発しないじゃないです
か
8切りところかもういいところか
もうこんなのドッキリじゃないじゃないとくれず開けてみます
おおおお見た目やすごい似てると思うじゃないですか
マーティ口が雑すぎってこれちょっとば寝ちゃうんじゃないですかああ猫このタブを
引いて順番に弾いてって言うが悪いとブルブル暴れだすらしい
やってみましょう
着装もないやー ok 隼輝でこれをやれば多分なんか
すーっ
部分が悪いという
それこわい
car
おっ
あー結構怖いだ
ブーブーですよえっみーちゃん今日ぷっ夏からジャン
ます
言いますそれ位
撮影の十字買ったよああああっ
顔はいたの
う絶対ドッキリアンケこれ見るからに三ツ矢サイダーのかうちゃんやんけ
させたの場合でもはからアカン
二がにバレたでこれは見るからに2おかしいやんけ
どう見ても水や大家ちゃんはなんやねんこの2パターンなんでこの2はまるでる水やだ
西八木4ままぁ大丈夫だろサティ多分きっかけ
カメラまであるやんけ完全にドッキリあ
前は今回は y のリアクション芸見せたるでー
[音楽]
me
dea
car
me あった